if I could redesign the world actually
that's been the question that I've been
trying to answer for the last several
years and it is in fact the topic of my
new book but with Anthony Williams it's
called macroeconomics a basic idea is
that we're not in a recession we're a
turning point in human history where
many of our institutions that are served
us well for decades or even centuries
are now stalled and unable to take us
forward whether it's our old models of
global problem solving based foundation
states or university newspapers are
collapsing media or and deep trouble the
music industry is is collapsing we've
got universities moving into a period of
big crisis the global financial system
needs more than some new regulation
needs a whole new modus operandi or old
models of the vertically integrated
corporation or health care or
transportation systems the city or
systems for energy all are frozen or
stages of a program the good news is
we've got a new medium of human
communications the internet the navels
has been intense all of these
institutions on an open network model
based on any set of principles
principles to me our collaboration
openness transparency sharing
intellectual property is electric inputs
or is interdependence and integrity
every institution needs to have
integrity as part of its bones part of
its DNA is this global economy and you
know this has happened once before
during feudal agrarian economy its
knowledge was concentrated in the tiny
hand flow along came the printing press
and people had knowledge and it didn't
make sense anymore for the church that
you're doing say and that
it didn't make sense for kings and
Nobles to be making all the decisions in
society we saw the rise to the
Protestant Reformation Martin Luther
called the printing press God's greatest
act of grace we saw the rise of
parliamentary democracy the saw the
creation of the University the modern
corporation industrial capitalism and
advanced prosperity over decades and
even centuries now we've got to move
forward to the new age of networked
intelligence where networks of glass and
air enable us to share our intelligence
and to bring our collective human values
for bear on the problems that face the
world that's what